hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians
are classy individuals or absolute
trash now here are your hosts
kevin ryan and h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast yeah
this is
are you garbage so show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find out
if they grow up to be classy
or they're just a big old piece of trash
oh yeah i'm your host holy coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here in
aunt dude's basement
she's upstairs sleeping it off yeah
easter sunday
yeah she got after it i have never seen
a woman get this drunk at an easter egg
hunt
in my life so she's upstairs chilling
okay good my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me he's the ceo of
are you garbage and international
businessman
gang the next time you're reaching for a
best pal do yourself a favor
and make it a kippy you will not regret
it i know i haven't
a little bit of cash yeah now he's
walking around his [ __ ] bank accounts
flush
all of a sudden i'm his best [ __ ]
friend again
he's got a couple stacks on him oh man
i'm checking on him like [ __ ]
like a sick ant he's got a couple of
jihads all of a sudden he's checking
yeah dude i'm getting called hey how you
doing kippy can i get you anything
you're doing good you're all right how
you feeling yeah
uh kevin james ryan ladies and gentlemen
hey gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video is
available
on youtube and those numbers i actually
have a document here
signed by all three governors of new
jersey pennsylvania
and new york that says those numbers are
true to roof true to [ __ ] roof uh and
then also patreon.com those numbers are
[ __ ] cooking too daddy oh
hooking we're about to be [ __ ] 10
stacks like it's nothing
hippie's going to disney world oh man i
got a water bed on the way
it just got stuck in the canal uh and
then
uh also guys raleigh and nashville 420
and 421 we're gonna be down there
at uh uh good nights and then nashville
zaney's yeah
get some [ __ ] tickets it's gonna be a
little bit of stand up it's gonna be a
little a little bit
uh live ayg with you guys where we ask
you questions you ask us
questions it's going to be a good
[ __ ] fun let's go yeah that's it
business out of the [ __ ] way
and how about a nice shout out to our
producer shortener the magic man he
makes us all look good
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen yeah what
up boys
got a hot one yo last week we got a
retraction from kippy um we did
i'm thinking i got i'm going to chip
away the next thing you're going to be
retracting on is cash back
i'm here for all the cashback warriors
you know who would have liked
trash back cashback what the [ __ ] guy
who pumped our gas in new jersey
wouldn't have mind fully popping in for
a gatorade grabbing a five you put cash
back at a [ __ ] drive-through
gas station all right maybe i'll go for
it to give the kids something but i'm
not getting ten dollars from [ __ ]
7-eleven yeah it's trash it's like
trying
we'll get into it that is neither here
nor there we could not be more excited
to have our incredibly special guest
royal new york
[ __ ] legend here with us today he is
a very funny stand-up comedian dj and
actor
you've seen him in the 25th hour the
bodega the jim gaffigan show
the characters laugh mobs laugh tracks
comedy knockout the chris gethard show
wild now the nightly show with larry
wilmore
the chappelle show ever heard of it and
gotham comedy live
and he has amazing podcast out right now
called juan app is dead ladies and
gentlemen do me a favor
give me a nice big round of applause and
i say this a lot
but this time i mean it for the one the
only
cipher sounds ladies and gentlemen on
the one end only what ups
i love it i love those credits where
it's like oh yeah that was good that was
good
that was good that was big that was big
how long has this show been running
about a year just past a year so you're
still calling it the new
the new podcast everybody's favorite new
podcast okay
we started this day one and we're stuck
with it it's working
cooking now it's cooking cooking we're
doing all right man thank you for
watching we're doing all right i'm happy
for you
we got you in here we're doing we're
going well yeah yeah yeah if i'm here
dude you i knew you before i started
doing comedy i knew cypher sounds yeah i
saw i've been
following you guys you know the clips on
instagram pop up and then i go check out
the show i'm like oh this is good
how do i get on this well your hair is
stupid as billy ass june
[Laughter]
it was a no-brainer i remember when i
first got up here and they used to make
fun of me
i didn't know what to do what's up you
guys we're hanging out was like me
reggie conquest derek gaines yeah monroe
martin
and he doesn't know hip-hop he doesn't
know anything from anything yeah
so you were like tweeting at everybody
and [ __ ] he goes who's this sippa sounds
guy
i don't know who he is we got to start
hanging out with him
so he got torched in the group chat
straight
i bought a bunch of super dry [ __ ] the
whole nine yards
my headphones just cut out uh-oh yeah
this is
[ __ ] studio's track it's garbage
technical difficulties here in england
and now it's going in and out you know
i'm a radio professional i know
we look like a couple of bozos now i
know when the things are going in and
out
yeah wait why am i starting to talk like
i'm from outside
what the influence is is it better now
is it on
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah nice yeah perfect
i might have stepped on it by actually
i'm sorry
i step on mine a lot and i get yelled at
like it's my fault i'm actually glad it
happened to somebody else so i'm not the
freak
that has never happened to anyone i am
mortified yeah it's coming out of
t-bone's paycheck at the end of the
month
what is so you're from the bronx you're
a bro
yes so give us the full story okay uh
born in the bronx to a puerto rican
father
and half puerto rican half irish mother
my mother had me when she was 16.
um my father died when i was three damn
yeah of uh okay
the story is okay the story is he
drowned
and then one of my crazy cousins calls
me up one day
drunk i don't know why he was mad at me
goes and you i know the truth about your
father he was in the streets
so insinuating that he died some kind of
gangster way that's a [ __ ] up this is
like yeah this is like i'm in my 30s you
know what i'm saying when this happened
i'm like what the [ __ ]
and i never even thought about it as my
mom and she's like yeah
he was in the streets but he definitely
drowned it was unrelated he was in the
bathtub
unrelated he drank he was fishing with
his friends he there was some kind of
accident it's this is very sad i don't
want to start off a fun podcast
it's okay he he drank he fell off the
boat but he lost his glasses is what
they
assumed because and then he was kind of
like really like legally blind
so he just couldn't see [ __ ] just damn
died oh man it's so sad dude there's
always sorry there's always a cousin out
there
there's that one they get a couple yeah
that want to say something [ __ ] up but
nothing he wasn't even
he's a very much younger cousin he
didn't know anything about my father
he was like 14. his mother was telling
him something you know i mean like
he wasn't even what did he ask for a
tour of the radio station and he shot
him down or
[Laughter]
my cousin started like wanting to come
to nightclubs when i was djing and like
i would let them come but then like you
got to carry crates you got to kind of
work
i got a bun i got a whole squadron
that's carrying crates
to get in and then i my cousins just
walk in for free like
popping bottles and [ __ ] so my thing
about if you help me carry crates into
the club you have to carry the same
crate
out of the club because what happens if
you get in for free then you start
drinking you're meeting girls
you start disappearing and i gotta carry
all the crates out
a guy runs a tight [ __ ] ship i'll
give him that one man in one man out i
like it you're a dj and you're carrying
crates out
yeah knew it was the worst my boy big
kev was my road matter he never he was
always with me
and if we both had two crates one in
each hand we were like
we need a new squad
[Laughter]
i'll carry one well as a comic that's
one thing but when the dj is carrying
his own records
that's a hard that's a tough look these
are hot clubs too yeah yeah you're lucky
i want to i want to hear a little bit
about that yeah yeah we'll get to it
so um so yeah so then um what part of
the
bronx i grew up uh my mom moved around a
lot
but uh my mom is from fordham in jerome
okay
where's worst intersection in new york
city
uh so that's like fordham fordham road
area
and then my godmother her name was susie
who's like what in the
in the in the hood it's your mom's best
friend is your godmother sure yeah yeah
she lived in in a gun hill road area so
those were my two
um what do you call it like a stomping
ground yeah but my mom
we always moved around a lot so bronx
park east is where we spent a lot of
good time that was the home of
like regis philbin oh shout out to the
same elementary school as regis
really yeah damn that's that's funko's
that's my claim
what are you doing i gotta get to the
club
i gotta guarantee it's great i read i
ran up on regis once
i'm telling you that was the worst loss
for me big dude
uh you or before we started recording
you mentioned columbo i'm a
big columbo abbott and costello jerry
lewis bam
frank i'm a huge frank sinatra fan i'll
tell you all about that and like regis
too like this is all from watching tv
with my grandmother we watch the jerry
lewis telethon
um so i'm doing we're about the same age
i'm a year older
yeah all that but my grandmother like oh
you know she was like my
my babysitter my mom was working so he
watched a lot of old [ __ ]
so uh well the thing with tv when we
were young
is we didn't have that option we had to
watch the
which turned out i think better for us
but we didn't have [ __ ] youtube and
all these wasn't a thousand different
choices
you had yeah in new york we had channel
two channel four
channel five channel seven channel nine
channel 11.
13 was pbs yeah and then spanish
channels
couple of univisions in the summer we
got two episodes of what's happening
maybe uh uh uh an all in the family then
a mash and yeah hogan's heroes
audit so i was at a broadcasting
uh awards ceremony upstate new york lake
george
and regis was one of the uh oh man regis
was one of the honorees that night
suit is he wearing a suit yeah we
wearing a suit and i was wearing a suit
and i never wear a suit
and uh i only wore it because i might
meet regis damn
dude i love it i love that man and i ran
up on him
i'm like regis i'm a huge fan i'm from
kruger avenue same block you're from i
went to the same school he goes
calm down kid
and i was like you're right you're right
you're right i should have known how to
run up on you you're right
that's great oh but yeah so yes i grew
up in the bronx
um and then uh i had a sister
five years younger than me and my mom
moved to california for two years it
didn't work out
moved back to new york wait did you go
you weren't with her yeah yeah yeah okay
we're in cali
in the bay area oklahoma like hayward
right next near oakland now what was she
doing
work-wise at that time well she went um
her her brother's ex-wife lived out
there so that was our connection we went
out there
she uh tried to become a
uh a california highway patrol okay what
she's trying to be a chip
real quick just to stop you right there
just for one second we're leaning
towards trash at this point yeah because
you mentioned brothers her brother's
ex-wife if you got if you got some
something cooking with you with a
relative's ex-wife that's not a good
look
and number two you mentioned godmother
yeah no one has ever mentioned anything
godmother
yeah no because you're like 100
yeah you got a lot of a lot of white
boys
i have aunts and uncles that i that
aren't my aunts and uncles that's like
oh yeah of course
like i was out of i was at easter part
of this weekend i'm like is that i don't
know jimmy and i'm like i don't
have an uncle [ __ ] jimmy yeah my my
godmother's daughter
is my cousin even though there's no
blood in any of this yeah yeah i don't
say god's sister
yeah that's weird that's my cousin oh
yes of course all right that makes sense
the the the apartment we had in the bay
area
the bookcases were the moving boxes
but cut out the front of it
and my mom i remember now i don't think
books are your main concern
was there books in them those
encyclopedias you know you always have
opinions you moved the encyclopedias
across the country
do you have encyclopedias no we were
[ __ ] see i think that might be thing
that we were like the last
i don't know every family had a [ __ ]
set everybody in the hood had
encyclopedias i don't know what it was
man i don't know what it was
[Laughter]
everybody always a good salesman that
hit the building and you all [ __ ]
bought
they always had them that's great and
then uh
my mom had a boyfriend and he used to
sell salami at the flea market on the
weekends
oh man dude selling cured meats in a
parking lot
ain't a good look just salami
like uh salami some every you know kind
of meat stuff all that stuff
specialist yeah yeah and then uh
pigeonholed again
he had his hand i got other options
we moved back to new york uh
everything is kind of whatever just a
regular my mom wasn't
like dirt poor we're never on welfare or
anything like that
working class family yeah yeah and my
mom did a great job as a single mom
because my dad died and then she had my
sister's father but he wasn't around
long
um and then in 10th grade my mom gets a
promotion she works with
fedex damn okay she gets a promotion
instead of being a driver she becomes a
dispatcher
okay you move to levittown long island
all right
so i go from the hood to very white
the most suburban right i think the
original
suburb yeah
there's another town right by where i
grew up yeah and all the houses are
exactly
exactly the same from what i remember
from my readings wasn't too
acceptant of minorities in in those
suburbs
not at that time no when they first set
them up that's what redlining comes from
yeah yeah yeah
yeah probably wasn't an easy ride yeah
but you know luckily it worked out for
me
cool uh and then uh we moved there so
that's why i always say i i speak white
because my three years in high school in
long island plus nassau community
college
i feel very i mean it probably saved my
life
but because two reasons one i got out of
the hood where like you know
people i was around were doing a lot of
crazy [ __ ] um
two i i hip-hop was just always around
when i grew up
it just was the music of the
neighborhood when i moved it got taken
away
so then i saw it sought it out okay
that's what led me down
the music dj trail because i had to go
find it
as opposed to it just being outside
every day and then that's where i
started djing and then that would lead
to me doing radio and
here i am i mean dude you were a kid
think about it you were a kid
in the bronx in the 80s and 80s yeah
that's [ __ ] bananas also for the
people that have never been
the broad like you go to the different
boroughs manhattan queens every like you
know
brooklyn they all have their own vibe
yeah the second you stepped foot in the
bronx
i don't know what it is you know you're
in the it's like yeah it's different
it's a
distinct different vibe in the box it's
very different it's because it's so
what i think it's so far from downtown
manhattan it's so far detached i feel
the same you feel like you're in a
different place
queens and brooklyn you're literally
just looking at you
you're right across the water where the
bronx you have to travel all the way up
manhattan island which is a long
island you know it's it's uh it's not
very wide but it's it's
yeah so you're like so far away i know
people from the bronx that have never
gone
they go downtown once a year yeah yeah
it's like to get to a doctor or you know
what i mean
some specialist or something yeah and
then um and then the bronx is
it's got they got an attitude it's it's
the only borough with a the
the only borough would have that's
the bronx and uh they will correct you
and then it's also the only
borough of new york city attached to
mainland america
every other borough is an island true so
there's
they have a little and then hip-hop came
from there yeah yeah yeah hip-hop and
yankees
two too many major players yeah
major players yeah and the 1980s you
were [ __ ] you were there
yeah but i didn't i didn't know what i
was seeing
now i look back and like damn i was part
of his i didn't i just was lit you just
were living
we weren't see people think hip-hop is
like it was invented in the 1970s in the
bronx
and they always think there was like a
man with like a beret
and a cigarette holder like i want to
invent a culture sure yeah
i mean like they didn't realize it was
being invented when it was invented it
was like
hey how can we get some [ __ ] at this
party
that's what people don't understand and
it [ __ ] worked
yo how do you put your girls into a
basement people always look at hip-hop
as like this
co it is a culture it is a movement but
at the time it was just like a guy like
i want to make some money and have some
[ __ ] dancing like thank you
[Laughter]
and how much of a contrast was when you
so when you moved
out to long island you must have been i
mean because i i always say
like i because you know we grew up in
the suburbs
you know and i wouldn't want to trade it
for the world yeah
but there is a thing that city kids do
have a slight advantage
as far as street smarts yeah over
suburban kids
of course yeah long island is a little
bit different because it's so close to
the city
but uh still so when you got out there
yeah
you know i mean yeah it was weird they
must have thought you were a public
enemy
yeah did you flex a little bit too like
um from the bra you know what i mean did
you wear it as a badge at all because i
would have
full radio raheem just blasting it
no man because i i was the nerd
in the bronx yeah i was the nerd but i
was very well protected i was uh
i was the guy i was literally the kid i
was in seventh and eighth grade doing
high school book reports for the like
the
street guys in my neighborhood yeah and
then they would take care of me you know
that's like an awesome i would i
literally did book reports and
one guy got so mad at me like yo you got
me you got me a [ __ ] a
like they're not gonna believe i got an
a i was like i'm sorry i didn't
i read the book two weeks in advance he
goes no just do this [ __ ] the night
before all right
do it like i would jerk off don't be
shooting for the stars that's awesome do
it tonight
just read half the book yeah read the
back
get back and he got so bad were you a
cliff note kid
uh no they were more confusing to me
than the regular
everything listening to you by the way
yeah everybody i always say get the
cliff
i used to read really fast for some
reason i just liked it
nice and then i got the encyclopedia so
yeah so like
he only had i had all the street smarts
sorry i had all the street smarts
but i didn't have to like use them like
gotcha like
they they taught me how to avoid trouble
yeah where they were like getting
into trouble gotcha yeah you're like
i've seen this [ __ ] before i can
sidestep
so then i go like to long island it's
all white kids but you know whatever
like my grandmother's white
right like my mother's mother's white so
like it wasn't like white people were
foreign to also the bronx is a very
mixed area yeah
you got regis yeah register but like the
bronx is like
grand concourse was like used to be like
all like rich jewish people and like
i grew up in an italian neighborhood
morris park it wasn't like white people
were foreign
uh like in some hoods where like in the
projects where it's like mostly black or
spanish
latino is the latinx latinx whichever
the right term is nowadays
sounds like a superhero yeah but yeah so
i go cutting that out and it was just
[Laughter]
i'd like to hear more about it gang this
podcast is sponsored by
better help let me ask you a question
there's something in your life that's
interfering with your happiness
something preventing you from achieving
your goals well as you know
i'm a huge mess there was some things
interfering with with my happiness
and my goals and that's why we started
working with betterhelp yeah the
fantastic people
at betterhelp betterhelp will assess
your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating with them in
under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not a
self-help line
it's a professional counseling done
securely online in many areas
the services available to clients
worldwide and it's fantastic
yeah guys it's easy you can log into
your account anytime and send a message
to your counselor that was given to you
you'll get a timely thought out response
for them so you and you can also
schedule weekly video and phone sessions
so you don't have to ever have to sit in
like a weird awkward waiting room type
deal i had to do that before i hated it
it's not fun the person that sees you
coming and going
it's it's not for me better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches
so they can make it easy and free to
change counselors
if needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and fi
financial aid is available if you do
need better help
wants you to start living a happier life
today visit betterhelp.com
garbage that's h e l p
and join over the 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
and they're recruiting additional
counselors in all 56 all 50 states
so special offer for are you garbage
listeners
you can get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
garbage folks if you're having issues do
it
to help you out gang real quick want to
talk to you about one of our new
favorite sponsors here on the show oh
yeah
we all know that quitting smoking stinks
i hate it and what stinks about it are
the devices that they give you to try to
quit smoking
like nicotine gum or patches i tried the
nicotine gum it didn't work
and there was no way i was jacking
myself up to a patch
of straight nicotine going in my body 24
7.
but our friends at fume have come up
with a solution
this thing is absolutely fantastic if
you're trying to quit smoking yeah guys
it's not a vape and it doesn't use
nicotine but instead uses these cores
let me say
that you stick right down the middle and
it's infused with the world super plants
that help you
successfully quit smoking from start to
finish plus they taste
pretty fantastic fantastic so head over
to breathefume.com that's
b-r-e-a-t-h-e-fume.com
and use promo code garbage and grab a
fume and check out the variety of plant
infused cores
to start today their conquer cores are
the number one core for quitting smoking
from start to finish so give it a shot
as you know i'm back on the bernies i'm
trying to get off them they sent these
things
they sent one for me for the big man and
for t-bone and we've been crushing them
they're great i'm cutting back on the
bernies it's an easy win for everybody
it works check it out uh fuma's already
helped over 30
000 customers worldwide from hundreds of
customers who have shared their quitting
stories on their site
head to breathefume.com that's
b-r-e-a-t-h-e
fume f-u-m and use promo code garbage to
save 10
and help a loved one or you quit today
now back
to the show um so yes then i moved to
long island there's all these white kids
and uh i remember one time we were in a
little like doing doing long island high
school white [ __ ] where like
they're like we're going to a party and
i was like oh [ __ ] yeah i love you know
great i've been going to parties all my
life let's go
and they started walking me into the
woods and i was like
what's happening here and then they go
and there's two kids there and they have
red cups right solo cups and they're
like five bucks and i'm like for what
they're like you gotta pay for a cup i
was like okay
and then we walk a little further and
there's just a keg in the woods
yeah yeah and i was like where's the
party they're like this is the party
party yeah yeah that's it
i was like what are you what's happening
right that was it man
i i never got to do it which i was
really jealous of
i mean we had cake parties we would have
them at someone's house yeah never in
the woods i was so jealous
yeah there was always a couple in the
woods yeah i imagine that would be like
what the [ __ ] going on
so yeah it was weird and then uh and
then like they had beef with some other
school
and like a pickup truck pulled up and
like six
big like football white dudes jump out
the back and start running towards us
and
everyone runs away and i'm like it's not
my beef
yeah i don't i don't know and i just
stood there and they killed my bud
i paid for this pay for this [ __ ] pumped
all the way out in the woods for this
and they run towards me and they're like
what's up i was like i
just moved here this got nothing to do
with me and then he was like all right
all right and they run
like i was like i just wanted a whole
day man it sounds like white people
problems
you guys got to take care of this but
everyone ran and i was like
this where i come from like
you know what beef is coming you know
what i'm saying like yo
someone got shot the other night be on
the lookout because they might want to
get revenge or some [ __ ]
so that's when i would just be like i'm
staying home this week sure because you
were expecting it but this was like
it's not my beef so why would i run and
uh it was like they like they looked at
me with my hood logic and they're like
yeah
yeah all right you're right makes sense
you're not antony or vito
you're not vinnie with the skinny are
you stubby what
but yeah so then i just walked home and
then uh that was my heist my high school
years
and then in my in do you know what five
percenters are
no no this is gonna be it's gonna take
too long i'm sorry no go ahead i like it
no of course
so cypher is a five percenter word five
percenter
the five percent nation is his group it
was very popular in the 80s and 90s
and it's basically uh you ever hear like
slang you ever hear hip hop records
where they're like peace god
you ever heard that peace god he's god
you know do you listen to the 90's yeah
yeah i i can't pull that one it's gonna
be a long one
cause it's like someone calls him a man
it's like what up god yeah
anyway it's a group okay picture this is
what it is a group like fleetwood mac
you know you know what the nation of
islam is sure like malcolm x
of course okay five percent nation a guy
was
in the nation of islam left
and then started his own group called
the five percent nation
but it's basically all the teachings of
the nation of islam without the religion
okay so instead of what they say is
this is not where i thought the episode
was fully take notes what they say is
instead of praying to the god and this
mystery god in the sky
the black man is god because all
civilization comes from the black man
okay from africa so it's a it's
basically a group like that all the
hip-hop groups in the 90s
were part of this if you listen to
wu-tang records there's all five percent
of talk in there
okay so i discovered that in the summer
between 11th and 12th grade so
i become a five percenter in the summer
i come back to school
and all of a sudden lou diaz is now
god's site for islam
[Laughter]
you're walking around third period with
a bow tie and a b no no no no he was
more militant
yeah i was more militant so i had a vest
with all these buttons and
stuff they weren't the guy i'm sorry
they weren't the guys that like would
dance or march behind public enemy
no those are the s1ws okay yeah so my
[ __ ] is like you
white devil you know like whoa you're
tuning into aunt
what happened to lou diaz over the
summer you're not coming to the next
kegger man
i told like i told my mom i don't eat
pork anymore she's like
okay i'm not gonna eat tonight then you
know pork chop
but yeah that's where cipher comes from
that's fantastic yeah
it's a much longer version but yeah and
then you kind of got out of that a
little bit
i it's i'm not heavily into it but i it
did change my
outlook on life it's basically seeking
knowledge i understand
everything about the five percentage is
seeking knowledge so that's where i got
my uh
my like my passion for like learning
different cultures and
i study all types i read all types of
[ __ ] so
very nice yeah seems pretty classy you
see that's the got a good head on his
shoulders for sure
as we i was nervous to come on here
because my trashing is weaves in with
we'll get it we'll find it there we'll
go we love interesting stories and
that's an interesting story i love that
um when you where did you guys in
levittown where you live did you guys
live in a single-family home
yeah so i technically lived in wanton
which is right
like literally like you cross over this
little bridge that was over the highway
and that was levittown my high school
was right there
but i lived in wanton what was the name
of the street
twin lane not pretty good this was
it was just you your mom and your sister
me and my mom and sister yeah so your
mom was able to afford her own home
yeah oh my there was a step dad in there
a little bit
sometimes yeah but your mom had her own
place yeah but was rented
still that's pretty good though you guys
are doing pretty good well we moved
there because of a
promotion yeah a decent but there was a
moment where
uh i remember i was at home from school
it was the first
we moved there like in the summer before
10th grade
that thanksgiving it was a knock on the
door like and i go to open the door
and there's these people there with
boxes of food for us
like hey you know this is a contribution
from the neighborhood
full turkey on the table yeah yeah like
i was like
you have a huge turkey like in your hand
some church group was like donating food
to us because we were the latinos in the
neighborhood
and i was like this is gross like
disgusting canned corn and [ __ ] like
we got the good [ __ ] yeah i'm always
shuffling it up she's throwing down and
we gotta play them a fungo on the table
you guys want to come in and have some
real food hit the [ __ ] bricks oh man
for this condescending edible
arrangement for you yeah yeah yeah we
just redonated it to another
kendra it was the next thanksgiving so
it was a little old but
what'd your mom say to that like what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] she came home because
i was just home alone like me and my
sister and then she comes home and she's
like what is this
do you go shopping i know some people
dropped it off and she's like
these poor these racist [ __ ]
i'm a that's dispatcher
funny
hi are your parents oh i know they're
not home but here here's a box of
canned cranberry sauce for you and yours
get the [ __ ] out of here
all right let's get into some more you
garbage here you go here we go all right
we're going to ask you a series of
questions
to determine whether you're garbage or
not i'm saying right now like you said
we're 50 50. okay you're a motivated
motivated individuals successful right
search for knowledge he sticks and moves
i feel like he's got a good head on he's
a smart guy
because the way we look it's economics
really don't play it right and even if
it did
you would have points in your favor okay
because your mom took herself out of a
situation and is this simple
and a better one right is this something
you win if you're garbage or
do you want me to be garbage out of
encyclopedias yeah
l through z we got him now you know what
it's not a hard you're just trying to
determine
yeah if you're trash yeah yeah yeah yeah
um all right
i'm on i'm leaning i'm leaning pretty
classy
i don't know um where do you stay now
where's your spot now
uh battery park city okay and you're
married
whoa whoa whoa whoa i don't know
yeah yeah yeah he told us about
shootings and [ __ ] yeah
asking
[Laughter]
let's get back to how my father died
who the [ __ ] you've been talking to
all right yeah married okay battery
park's not i mean that's that's a little
bit yeah that's ours
and also joe it's like you've been you
know uh you've
you've been successful is that the one
of the questions no would you worry
that was the background okay just
kidding yeah that's because i will tell
you this
uh i moved i got that apartment
uh he might have got it in the trash
it's technically my grandmother i was
looking i was looking for an office in
the city because i had a house
in jersey i bought a house in jersey
with cash
from this from djing nightclubs nice
uh so i was looking for an apartment to
be uh like a recording studio so i could
have my like an office in a recording
studio
so uh it's in 2004 i got it
and there was an incentive to for people
to move back into that neighborhood
after 9 11.
okay so the the rent was way cheaper
than it should have been
and to this day it still is because i
was like they were like your grandfather
fathered and kind of yeah
to move back here was like desolate
afternoon right yeah so i don't know if
that makes it trashy or not but it's
i'm not paying he got it on a discount
yeah no that's a smart new york thing to
do yeah yeah
there's no shame i know people that
lived in [ __ ] styletown yeah for
years
yeah they paid like [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] 300 bucks because their
grandmother owned it right
back in the day they got wise to that
though yeah um
but you did bring up something
interesting you bought a home in in new
jersey with money from django yeah
and you said you paid cash does that
mean there wasn't there was no mortgage
no no no i didn't i didn't pay the whole
thing cash
you brought you you brought like a
duffel bag from a shoebox
oh my god what i brought what type of
shoes though was it nikes
always nice i brought a shoebox
for the for the closing like the all the
fees you have to pay for the closing the
down payment you can pay that in cash
no the lady the lady was not
the lady was like like we had the
meeting i should i go in and like okay
now we need to check for this this is
for the title this is for the down
payment this is for the
and i i pull out the box and she goes
oh mr diaz you've been watching too many
little wayne videos
she told me i had to go like go get like
a cashier yeah
they had to i held up the whole clothes
the people who are selling houses are
like oh wow that's fantastic i didn't
know
i was like that that's how you buy a
house
throw the money in the table tell but it
is the [ __ ] out they were shaking their
head at me like oh
mr diaz no see that's that that's the
back and forth like
he can buy he's he's hustled hard enough
to go to get a
house in the burbs but he shows up with
a shoebox full of games and i will say
this the reason i
asked the question was because i think
it would be more garbage
if you paid the house completely off
with cash a check or whatever right
but you did the smart thing and you got
a mortgage all that kind of stuff now
why is that
pretty classy a mortgage builds credit
yes
mortgage bills mortgage builds credit
and also it
opens up you can do other stuff with
that money rather than sitting in a
house
right you know because i know if all of
a sudden i got a bunch of money
i would do the garbage opposite i would
[ __ ] go buy a house that i really
couldn't afford
right and pay cash i'm not gonna have
more yeah
yeah i would do the uncle i like that
better though i like having no payments
sure if it gives you peace of mind for
sure yeah but more than likely the
person that does that isn't accounting
state tax property tax etc cetera
correct
[Laughter]
about those jersey taxes real quick and
they sent me the tax bill and i was like
that's not
that wasn't included you got the [ __ ]
shoe box
what the [ __ ]
oh man oh that's beautiful
beautiful beautiful okay all right all
right here we go
some couple things so not personal
questions but
how you operate i guess uh you have a
toaster at the house
okay toaster oven or toaster uh
okay uh uh-oh that's a toaster oven the
toaster oven
yeah i like it toaster ovens are good
okay you say that but i've never heard
anybody
where i said do you have a toaster yes i
have a toaster i asked him if he was a
toaster oven
he acts like you know he's got a pet
snake or something
no people are always a little
self-conscious to tell people i'm gonna
tell you what i'm gonna tell you why i i
froze a little
i got i over covered uh
i don't know how to cook at all okay so
i had nothing else to do so i started
just fooling and trying to eat better i
lost a lot of weight
gained it back thanks kovitz yeah um but
i decided to start just
trying to chef up little simple meals
and in the process of learning how to
cook
i uh got an air fryer for my birthday
okay the airfryer's also a toaster oven
yeah so i don't know if that i don't
know where that is fine no no
it's not i don't know where i stand on
air fryers to begin with they're
it's not the air fryer that's like a
bowl it's like a
door you know it's a toaster like it
opens up but i got it like a convention
here's the connection yeah here's the
thing yeah there was a certain point
in the 90s where we got we went too far
with that stuff
yeah you had a [ __ ] tv with a fan and
an actor
yeah so anything any combo it's a tough
look
it's a tough one okay well there was
only one that was classy
which was the vhs dvd yeah for a short
time
yeah yeah that was it so i had yeah so
that's a new i had a toaster oven that i
had for a long time but when i got the
airfry i was like i could just use this
so all right the reason i asked a
question because if you had a regular
toaster i was gonna ask do you keep it
out or do you put it away
okay because my family's pretty trashy
my mom
uses the toaster and then puts it away
back in the cabinet puts it away is
garbage yeah yeah really back into the
cabinet yeah
it doesn't just leave it out like like a
toaster is like an appliance on a
counter his parents are a little kooky
they unplug every appliance when they're
not using it the washer
but don't you want your counter to look
clean yeah but it's also a kitchen i
i mean i feel like getting a toaster
away yeah if you're hiding small
appliances
a blender i get put it under the [ __ ]
counter but a toaster you use it right
there so you leave your
you leave your toaster oven air fryer
slash yeah but it flips up
slash laptop wait what do you mean it
flips up it's a
it's it's it flips off it like tucks it
like a like a tumble bed
yeah yeah it's like a murphy bed of
toast
[Laughter]
murphy bed you have an in-wall air fryer
is that in the wall it what's the brand
food ninja something
all ninjas like this kind of hold
on no it's longer
putting in food in jojo or ninja or
foodie or something like that that one
looks pretty close yeah i'll give you
that this might be classic
the commercial is what got me oh you
bought it off the commercials are bad
look
at this let me see that i think that's
the one let me see
let me see
yeah that's it two forty nine reefers
that fits a whole pizza though i'll give
them that this thing might be classy no
this is good
it flips up too i don't know dude if
you're cooking bagel bites in an el
camino that's no good
ah this is pretty this is pretty good
the fact that he bought it
this guy's back and forth i can't get a
read on him
it's a nice piece of equipment 250
retail 250.
but he bought it off a commercial he saw
yeah i'm on the fence all right this
guy's going to be right down the middle
all right you're a new yorker
i live in new york currently you have a
washer dryer in the unit uh
uh yes in the unit you have it
yes yes why didn't you want to tell us
that yes uh
in case there's landlords listening
because they're illegal in those
buildings
uh yeah no it's in the uni yeah so you
do it there you don't drop it off or
anything
right you don't wow that's pretty shady
about this i don't know about the
strangest things
have you ever been in a go-kart uh well
[Music]
um
oh that's a tough one i used to have
that though
i used to have that in new york it makes
sense a little bit i remember one time i
was looking to sublet a place the girls
like we got in
in unit washer and i'm like oh great it
was just one of those things in the
bathroom it's like a salad spinner yeah
i'm like no
[ __ ] way get out of here
you got a pedal on a bike
in unit washer dryer that's class all
right now
specifically you this could be classy or
trash okay
because of where you grew up to time
frame et cetera except it's all relative
were you ever a member okay before you
got big were you ever a member of a
studio audience
no you never went to like a daytime show
or anything like that no
never okay never it's pretty good never
i wasn't
either way and i met regis i went with
yom when yom was doing uh
did you really the merit yeah me derek
monroe reggie we all went and regis was
the guest
yeah man that guy's a star well that's
why i asked him specifically that
because
it could be normally that would be class
like yeah i went to jerry springer with
my
aunts that's that's no that's garbage oh
garbage yeah but
you being where you were from you could
have been like yeah i [ __ ] i went and
saw the first phil donahue show or yeah
i mean or something like that never
studio audience yeah okay
okay um have you ever bought a pair of
skechers
no okay never he was offended by oh my
god i was i was i was in uh
uh charleston south carolina last week
with jared freed mm-hmm
oh my god you know jared freeze yeah we
just had him only two weeks ago oh my
gosh oh yeah that's right i saw that
oh his audience whoo the hottest
it's a hot it's all hot 90
hot white girls it's bananas it's crazy
dudes
are girl the boyfriends of some of the
girls
or whatever and uh man this girl just
i was talking to this one girl she was
so cute
and uh i'm talking to her and she was
wearing some sandals but she worked at
that bar
but she wasn't working that night she
came to see jared gotcha and i go let me
ask you a question
when you're behind this bar what you got
on the feet and she goes skechers and i
said
yeah they're so comfy though
the high arch the high arch i don't give
a [ __ ] about your high heart
that's a work you can't judge a nurse
for wearing nursing shoes reeboks are
comfortable adidas are comfortable
right there's a couple flyknits yeezys
they're all comfortable sneakers
sketchers
i would imagine you probably had pretty
good access
to all that kind of stuff when you were
coming up especially around the time
period
sketchers no did you have an original
pair of jordans like
no i wasn't into jordans i was in i just
got into jordan's like recently in like
the last five years
okay i hated jordans huh yeah i love the
original ones yeah
why i just couldn't no no no no we were
we were never
there was no way i mean it wouldn't
matter
my mother was never going to spend that
money on
on on a pair of john what do you mean
pull them off you mean your mom wouldn't
buy them or you couldn't wear them now
i couldn't really wear them now no it
just doesn't fit that's in your head
you think always you put you put them on
and you walk with confidence
calm toby get me a pair he's carrying
wear for wearing prescription shoes he
can't
he can't get into a [ __ ] pair of
jordans i'm sorry i'm wearing a pair of
this podiatrist is going to be furious
i'm wearing a pair of lipitors lipitor
air
okay no sketchers but i've never bought
a pair of knock-off shoes and tried to
pass them off
uh yes when i was young yes yeah i had
uh
wild styles which were uh
fake shell toe adidas okay uh
four stripes
and then and then i'll tell you this um
even in my heyday when i was making buku
bucks on the radio
there was a spot that and it was like
in uh uh 28th street and broadway
there's like all these like wholesaler
like
costume jewelry yeah sure fabric
so design like a lot of african guys
outside and they wear like
fake yankee hats and stuff there was a
guy who had fake air force ones
and we would go and we'd pull up and
we'd buy like 10 pairs yeah
because white air force ones were just
you always needed them uh-huh and i
don't wear i never wear sandals i never
wear anything
open-toe any sales nothing like that so
if i'm going to jamaica or puerto rico
i always get a fresh pair of air force
ones and those are my beach shoes
yeah yeah yeah so they were like that's
trash
hold on that's [ __ ] beautiful no
that's foreign he's wearing knockoff air
force ones on the beach
and then i leave jamaica and i leave him
why
why what why are you losing they're
probably 20 bucks they were like
they were probably like 40 bucks and he
can't wear them in the city he'll get
called out he's a big
i would wear him only they would snipe
him walking into the building
shit's his wack yeah saying nike oh why
dude no
because here's the thing here's what
they were what they weren't was we
we they're from the the nike factory
but they either had a small flaw or they
were stolen
[Laughter]
so a lot of guys a lot of guys are still
expecting this dollar yeah they steal
them
a lot of guys in china wherever they
make them they they
they steal them off the belt or whatever
they're made on
so they don't have the nike they don't
they don't get to the boxing
sure but they're the actual sneakers i
believe you
yeah yeah yeah yeah we did that a couple
times
all right i gotta know why why we're on
this um
uh were you ever a lugs guy okay
[Laughter]
man this guy's trash he had to have some
questionable fashion choices
no lugs were never okay my mentor funk
master flex
had a lugs shoe deal he did i'll give
him he was the only one he was
he was it was him he was the only dude
pushing those flex was the guy flex was
a genius flex was always the guy
you don't go after the number one or the
two guy because they already got jay-z
and nas and biggie whatever you go after
the number three guys you got a big
check from the
go for lunch wants to be number one
so he made a deal with lugs i'm in a
lugs
i'm in two lugs tv commercials
and did you know that
dude i've been [ __ ] on lugs for like
20 years i found it on
i found it i looked it up on google i'm
in a lugs commercial
and then like a lugs magazine ad no a
pre-dead
scythe well whatever he's working though
i got to give him that i never
i never i never wore them
but i i was part of the campaign sure
yeah yeah i got a nice she gave me
that was like he gave me i think a five
or
ten thousand dollar check and i'm i mean
i'm 22.
you know what i mean and the flex and
that means flex got a i'm 34.
i'd put on a pair of lugs right now
absolutely lex had to get a hundred
thousand maybe more yeah he gave me like
five or ten i forget what it was
but i was i i was livid damn i was
living but so yeah so
if you search cypher sounds lugs it will
come up oh i'm going to
for sure that's so funny i had no idea
that's great damn oh
logs were the toughest i don't know
where i'm going i don't know which side
i'm on have you ever been to
vacation that is sandals or hedonism
are you you know this stuff right no
dude no idea okay
we're just good at sniffing out the
trash no okay
and some got some guy who buys knock off
air force ones in midtown and wears them
on a beach in jamaica is probably going
to see it okay speaking of jamaica
ever never sandals never heating
on my own accord okay what hot 97
had a deal with hedonism two in jamaica
i remember i remember the act yeah we
would do a hot night hot night jamaica
and you could win tickets to go to heath
so that was the only time if i ever went
to jamaica i either went to um
the classy joint uh half moon
in montego bay which is classic sounds
nice and now i go to rock house which is
amazing okay but i go to jamaica a lot
but um
but why is that can i ask that why why'd
you make it i'm just a jamaican at heart
like
reggae music dance home music it's like
my culture i love it
it's like a new year and then and then
also i know the guy that uh
yeah also also i
no my best friend is a part owner in one
of these hotels in
um in uh in in the grill called
skylark okay but it's yeah it's but like
it's funny because it's like
touristy skylark which is beautiful
touristy like it's like in the morning
sure but um yeah so i went to hedonism
for that and
first of all sidebar new nude
beaches it's disgusting they're not good
there's a reason bikinis were invented
yeah like also like i was like oh we
going to a new like i'm kind of like
i i'm kind of shocked like i'm not like
i'm not like one of those freaks
publicly like i get down with a girl in
in private but in public i'm not like
one of those
like i don't even like strip clubs i
start feeling bad for the girls yeah
but i'm like oh nude bj i'm like
giggling like ooh it's gonna be crazy
it's all
old fat people like yeah it's gross
yeah hot people don't go to those things
yeah watch a bunch of me's with money
yeah it's like
old used gray head used
a little stinger hanging out
what would that night and tail what
would that happen it would be like on
there it would be like a weekend
it was called hot night but it was like
a weekend so it'd be like a there'd be
like a
a you know a day party like a brunch
kind of party vibe and then be parties
at night
and then we'd have like uh different
artists performing that night so almost
like
private concerts yeah not a bad giveaway
no it's pretty great
yeah it was great radio used to really
flex on giveaways back in the day man
yeah really you know it's like you know
it was me and like
six other jocks from the radio um and i
wasn't
even a high jock at that time it was
just like they're not gonna send the
main guys
and we would dj and do parties and then
we'd have like mr vegas or sean paul
perform
before they were like really big you
know and it was just like and it would
be like
40 hot 97 listeners and then the regular
people at the
at the resort if you could call that i
told you that's almost classy it's not
bad
i thought do i just can't get a read on
this [ __ ] guy seriously
everything's got a little bit of trash
to it every classy thing he does is
rooted
i like the island and the spiritualness
of it and the fruit and the people
actually my cousin
my buddy tim he's an owner
i get the midweek special because that's
empty the kid i grew up with in
levittown rent scooters on the beach
uh uh you ever heard of the restaurant
miss lily's here in the city
of course yeah okay miss lily's is the
guy who owns missiles owns this hotel
okay so there's a miss lilly's in the
skylark ah
is that the one on seventh and eight
yeah that's true there's one there and
there's one in houston okay
it's actually really good yeah so well
my boy is like a
a co-owner he's like i don't know what
you call it yeah
whatever or something yeah so so he was
in the room next door to me
so every time i would listen when he was
leaving his room
i know he was going to get breakfast and
i would just go with him so that i could
[Laughter]
i respect the move for sure shout out
max glazer yo
that's funny man holy [ __ ] dude
um what else we got what else we got
when was the last time you were in a
wave pool
um a while yeah a while okay
i don't i haven't been in a i haven't
taken my shirt off
and uh publicly yeah in a pool setting
in a
long time probably what i don't know
what year is it do you know do you swim
with the t-shirt on if you go
no no no no no you just don't go no no
like
i'll go in a pool i won't go in the
ocean how come no no no cause i gotta
untie his sneakers
i'd be swimming in air force i don't
like to get water that'd be awesome you
come walking out of the
out of the water you still got the air
force once on
i don't i don't i don't i don't like
going in the in the ocean from a beach
i'll jump off a boat
but i don't like walking in that slime
okay i mean i don't like things touching
my feet when you're walking into the
ocean
from the sand you know what i mean but
if we're on a boat like a yacht i'll
jump in
because it's like you can't touch the
bottom sure i mean and it feels cleaner
also yeah i mean not very many people
have been guests on the shows have been
been on a yacht they don't have an
opinion to be like
oh well when i'm on a yacht i jump into
the wall how many times have you been on
the yacht
a good amount of time yeah yeah i'm
friends with he knows jay-z
it's pretty good yeah i've been on some
i've been on some cool yeah
that's pretty classy i'm the um i know
but he's jumping off too like an animal
i guarantee jay-z off the [ __ ] yacht
i've been i've been lucky man i've been
on some cool [ __ ] man
i'm like you know what it is people just
like me like
i be like you're a nice guy they're like
hey i'm loving dj
uh you know on the third night of the
cruise we're having a little
get-together we want some cool like
soulful jazzy music with the guests but
i don't just
fly in for the third night i'm on the
whole thing you know what i mean
so it's pretty classy i watch below deck
pretty nice
um what was the name of your
pediatrician going up
do you remember uh no
no no i don't remember that well
cut that one out yeah it's kind of bad
um how many pairs of dress shoes do you
own
none zero i don't wear shoes i do not
wear shoes
what if you gotta go to a wedding nope
sneakers all the time always
do you have a suit to put on right now i
have suits i got suits
ballpark like two or like seven suits
yeah
um i got four
nice ones and then i'll have and then i
got and then i'll have like
like i got like six or seven like
blazers that i'll throw on with like an
open button down
and and nice g like black classy g-star
jeans
okay you know i mean but like is that
you know it's like like something
somewhat dressy yeah yeah yeah yeah
gotcha yeah but
but i gotta yeah i got like i got some
custom suits
but i go to the i go to this guy and i'm
like i'm
going to wear sneakers so like hem the
bottom of course so it looks right with
sneakers
a little longer yeah i don't i hate
shoes i won't wear she's pretty close
the only time
i would ever wear shoes would be for
some like if i was in a movie
and it was part of the part of the
character yeah obama could be like i
need your dj the white house i'm like
i didn't go you mentioned jay-z i
there's a famous party
every grammy season is called the roc
nation brunch
yeah it's all your favorite rappers
dressed to the tea like just to the
nines i'm going to the next one
you're not i'm going to wait until
you're walking down the hall and like
hey where are you going
are you going i was managed by roc
nation rock nation is my family yeah
right
shout out to og won shout out to dez
this is my family and they're like
you're gonna dj the next
uh roc nation brunch there was one in
new york wherever the grammys are is
where the brunch is
and i go okay you gotta dress up and i'm
like yeah dress up no problem they're
like you got to wear shoes i'm like you
know
you know you manage me yeah you know i'm
not wearing shoes
in my contract that you send to
promoters when they try to book me says
will not wear shoes so you know i'm not
wearing shoes
and they're like no but for this you
have to i'm like i'm not doing it
and and this is the biggest party of the
year and i said you know what
i'm not doing it i'm not going and
they're like you're really not going to
go to the brunch i'm not going
i'm not going and i stayed home and it
was literally like what
you didn't go it was like two blocks
from where i lived battery park
it was like some some
one of those halls you rent like fancy
halls sure
tribeca joints and and it was literally
two blocks walking distance from my
house and i didn't go
jeez i've been throwing a pair of penny
loafers no man no
i have my i have weird
non-negotiable
i'm there for the cool factor got no
shoes
speaking of cool factor have you ever
owned any of the following
okay do you own any swords
[Laughter]
num chucks no yo-yos
no chinese stars uh have i ever
yeah yeah chinese stars yes they're hot
in the 80s yeah
hot and they were hot in the air you go
to uh you go to the little
uh the little chinatown you know where
they sell like
just candy and bags and stuff sure and
you go you want to
go in the back you go in the back room
and there's like weapons
they were so [ __ ] awesome and it was
i never really heard
i don't think i ever heard one story of
somebody getting hit in the face with a
chinese star
which you would think how deadly of a
weapon they are yeah then there would
have been stories about that
the people that had them never have
friends so no
i think they didn't know how to use them
yeah no they would throw and they would
fly all over the place i've i've seen
people get messed up with nunchucks
i've seen it i've seen it not correctly
yeah you know not like of course it's
just like bias
[Laughter]
okay all right man it's equations i
don't know how i'm doing over there
you're doing good
all right i got one this is this is a
new one um when you're getting
you're getting out of the shower right
okay how do you dry yourself off do you
get out of the shower completely then
dry yourself off
do you dry yourself off in the shower or
do you do like a half and half type
thing
basically do you do you limit the amount
of moisture that's going to go on to the
correct yeah onto the floor emma and the
right in the shower kind of guy
okay okay i dry off in the shower
completely
uh i mean completely i mean i don't get
dressed in the shower
i i always keep the towel i got the hook
by the
shower sure i dry off enough to where i
didn't wrap it
and then you're good to walk around yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right
pretty good cause i'll do i'll just get
out like an animal i get yelled i'll
just get out
dude i'll get out i'll [ __ ] you dry on
the mat i'll i'll just do it yeah i just
it's like
i have no regard okay i'll go into the
shower i'll go into the bathroom not
realizing that
i don't have a clean pal still that's
the worst feeling in the world don't get
into the shower i'll shower
yeah [ __ ] rip that thing open and
i'll walk all through the apartment
looking for a towel
my girlfriend with my girlfriend
screaming at me
but it feels so good when that cold air
hits your butt here's the thing
you mean you go all around the apartment
looking for attack you don't have
all your towels i mean i go into the
bedroom again
where is it pulling it off the cat like
an easter egg
i walk to the freezer and i get my towel
like a gentleman in the shower
yeah have you ever brushed your teeth i
i used to because my mom
does that okay but i don't like it real
i don't like
big thing on the podcast really bad i
was against it for a long very long time
until last week i tried it
yeah and i did it i did it today it's a
game changer really is a game
i'm a hot shower guy okay but i like
brushing my teeth with cold water
yes okay same way and uh yeah i don't i
don't uh i don't what's the benefit
what's the benefit for me which i'm
learning is i
exit the shower completely clean okay i
go
i can now put something on my face i
don't have it's just like i'm i'm
still the cleansing process is complete
i'll sometimes brush my teeth before i
shower
okay give them that same thing i'm like
yeah i understand that because you're in
the shower and your breath is hot but
you're cleaning off
yeah i'll brush my teeth before i take a
shower that's pretty good i don't like
it in the shower 100 episodes
also like the the the your toothbrush is
in the shower like around he keeps his
in there i can reach mine forever
yeah it feels like i don't even i even i
cover
my toothbrush because i don't even want
the [ __ ] fumes i'm a big i was a
i just started wait wait a minute wait a
minute your own home
yeah you cover your toothbrush yeah i
yeah with what
with like a it's in like a case like a
travel case
uh yeah see those things get way funkier
no i clean it often
you sure you gotta you ever pick one of
those up and they just smell like [ __ ]
yeah no no i clean i have a um
amazon is the best i have a like a straw
cleaner
okay you clean those metal straws yeah
and i clean the toothbrush case yes
that's classic
that's not charging me it's weird but
it's classy
he's got no [ __ ] on his [ __ ] he's got no
poop particles on his head yeah
that i can't i can't i'm not a fan of
any
i don't think that really no okay well i
have the science on it
i do what do you mean it doesn't exist
there's no way you take a poop there's
particles all over you
on purpose 100 so but also i found
they did it on mythbusters years ago and
i used to be like a big [ __ ]
germaphobe
um there's no difference there's poop
the thing is there's poop particles
everywhere yeah there's no difference to
it being outside the bathroom
there's no difference being in the
kitchen or in your bathroom there's the
same amount of poop particles
poop particles throughout like that
that's gross yeah
this is so that's what made me go that's
what made me like finally
right yeah i could see that because
there's something like uh
i saw something once where they were
like doing tests on money
oh money oh they get it oh yeah
cash money disgusting they did it when
mcdonald's put in the touch screens
recently
they did a study on that don't ever
touch them oh yeah
right yeah it's bad it's bad
because you know the thing is like
that's the same thing about keyboards on
computers at work
where your keyboard is filthier than the
toilet at your job oh yeah they say cell
phones are disgusting disgusting
yeah what am i gonna do i need myself
yeah yeah yeah i gotta choose
i gotta i'm tick tocking it
oh man i gotta keep up with these kids
what do you want from me
while we're on the subject of trash
garbage i
downloaded tick tock because i was like
i spend all my energy on instagram and i
should be spreading out
my social media presence it's in our
business you have to yeah of course
i have not posted one thing and i'm a
[ __ ] junkie
i i almost deleted it this morning i'm
i'm i i look forward to the time where
i'm like okay i'm about to lay down
go to bed i don't even watch tv anymore
i just i fell asleep
i woke up my thumb was still on my
screen i woke up
and then and flicked another one
it's so bad that's trash and then my
algorithm is all [ __ ] up it's just big
titty white girls
yeah and like dating like what's the
worst time you've been
ghosted i don't know why well they they
think they know
i was the same way they think they know
you so i was just getting all these like
hot chicks as well and i'm like well i'm
gay you know whatever
uh so but then it stopped and now i get
all which i
enjoy is i get all uh rap battles
like all the kings yeah yeah yeah that's
all i get
that and like i get that in iphone hacks
oh that's pretty good i love iphone apps
that's not bad
can be useful for educational purposes i
guess i've never
i've definitely used some of the iphone
hacks i wouldn't i would i went on at
once and
yeah it was all like young girls dancing
i was like okay i'm too old for this
like i can't be looking at it i'm just
in big titties on tick tock yeah
um all right i got one have you ever
signed up for a free trial knowingly you
were going to
immediately no stop it afterwards no i
never do that
because i know i'm gonna forget to
unsubscribe
yeah i only put things that i'm gonna
actually pay for okay
i have respect i can't get you with that
unsubscribe they know the trashiest
thing is setting an alarm in your phone
for like the 18th or whatever
i've gone i've done some things where
it's gone all the way
to the credit card part and then i go
i'm not putting my credit card
yeah i know because i go i'm not gonna
do it yeah i'm not gonna unsubscribe
yeah that'll make you flinch real quick
dude i believe i've belonged to planet
fitness for like 37 years they're like
you gotta come in and turn us
i'm like i know you ten dollars a month
for the rest of my life
i never want to see they won't do it and
the only way they get their money is if
you ever try to re-up again
and you can never go back to a plan of
fitness they'll try to bang you out i
can't buddy
we'll be okay i've been around
[Laughter]
have you ever cooked onion rings at home
um
like you mean not made them but just had
frozen onion
instead of making like fries in the oven
you ever made onion rings
and yes that's trash yes but that's but
that's
with the new air fryer it was recently
the air fryer slash tv slash all right
i'll give you that
yeah it was recent follow-up how do you
feel about the pizza burger
you mean a burger with mozzarella tomato
sauce yeah
no okay i i'm a diner guy
okay i'm a diner guy me and my
grandmother always go to the diner
and a couple times i'm like i'm going to
get a pizza burger and i never it never
took
on paper it makes a lot of sense the
execution isn't great
literally my two i'll do hamburger meat
on pizza though
what how do you get that i mean
meatballs no hamburger meat
it's not a thing in new york really but
if you go out of town i don't hate it
like if you go to like uh cause i don't
eat pork okay
so like the pizza hut and the dominoes
and those type of oh yeah i've seen
ground but yeah they'll do ground beef
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can get ground
beef like we would get five five five
dominoes
you get like pepperoni bacon and ground
yeah in the hood we say hamburger meat
sorry
brown beef put that in my personal file
yeah yeah so i don't like a pizza burger
because burgers and pizza is my two
favorite [ __ ] foods
right but i'll do the hamburger meat on
the pizza
have you ever made a pizza bagel at home
uh
once as a no not a pizza bagel
uh uh uh uh english muffin
pizza english muffin extract classic
that was that was there's nothing trashy
about the [ __ ]
i don't care what you put on it english
muffin classy you know what's funny i
used to i grew up on english muffins but
i haven't gotten
i've never went and bought it on my own
it was just always at my mom's house do
yourself a favor go get yourself one
pack of times they stink dude what are
you doing what do you mean
the smell of them no no they just
there's
they're
not
better breakfast bread you've sent some
asinine things in this podcast
it's the craziest thing i ever heard
there's something about an english
muffin like i haven't had it in so long
golden brown crispy but the thing is you
gotta watch them because they burn
fast you gotta watch them
you know who watches toast you don't
watch toast yeah toast you can set it
and forget it and you gotta make it
like a cat you leave it yeah and this
muffin is like you gotta because it
starts blacking it then you go get it
and then you put that butter on an
english i'm gonna get a pack today
the nooks and crannies i think one time
my wife bought um
some you know like a like a whole wheat
gluten-free
thomas oh was not right i get the
original
the original and also i'm a cinnamon
raisin guy i don't like cinnamon raisin
but not really yeah
but i could see how that would be good i
don't like
raisins okay what's why do they always
make raisins
i hate raisins what's the reason ain't
doing much for you i love
a trail mix with the m m's sure
i gotta take out the raisins yeah of
course i'll sit in front of the tv
so you like eminem
like the peanuts and the uh and uh
whatever other shit's in there cashews
or whatever
i don't like i don't like a raisin and i
don't like you know what else i'm upset
about
i feel like raisins might be a white
person thing
my kids like raisins i like raisins okay
my kids like rihanna some people like
them
uh why can't they do the oatmeal cookie
without the raisins
they can and they do it's a little
chocolate chip and it's probably where
is that
it's the best cookie ever i love it it's
not that popular
but you find them sometimes i think it's
pretty much for me it's my favorite
cookie i'll bite into like an
oatmeal raisin because i love the
oatmeal cookies
but then i gotta like it's like a fake
noodles yeah yeah okay
around the raisin you like fig newtons
no no no no
love them love fake newtons yeah well as
a kid i hated him but i had one recently
i was like this is not bad
you're not you're yeah when you were a
little kid
between that and the [ __ ] chips ahoy
i'm starting a revolution if i get
[ __ ]
if i find fig newtons in my [ __ ]
chips my mom tried that [ __ ] once get it
did not fly
i looked her dead in the eyes and threw
the packet down
go back to the store
not in my house all right this is big do
you toast a bagel
yeah he's a what yeah wait now stop hold
on
rephrase the question stop stop you're a
new you're
you're you're a new york kid yeah you go
to you you saturday morning whatever
yeah you go to a bagel place you get
fresh bagels yeah you're toasting that
bagel
wait am i getting a pack to bring home
or again you're just getting it
there yeah i'll toast it i'll tell you
everything
everything bagel scallion cream cheese
scooped out
huh squishy snapped out scoops out
classy
scooped out scoops out is the classic
the noodles
scoop cipher sounds toast is big
scoop there it is that commercial is
killing it but
i love it wow it's so good we're big
components of the
of the fresh new york city bagel to not
be toasted
toby disagrees so you're the first
you're the first one that's agreed with
it
you know you do toast it yeah he wants a
toast you gotta toast the bagel period
we don't think you need to toast it what
about a buttered roll
that's such a new york thing yeah it's
very new york new york
new york i got no opinion on the butter
roll i got hard opinions
on the butter roll you don't toast
butter oil toast
it's horrible and it's just that coffee
that's that's i don't even drink coffee
it is i like i like a bunch that's the
breakfast in the morning like in the
bodegas
it's just butter buttered rolls butter
butter on a roll on a roll
that's it it's delicious it's so weird
to see like you know
a [ __ ] tin knocker with like the
construction you got a hard hat on he's
like
let me get a buttered roll is that a new
york thing oh yeah oh very new york
because i got uh bacon egg and cheese
is a new york thing too oh yeah yeah the
guy that we did the
the show for in charleston he's a new
york guy he he was part owner and down
the hatch and off the wagon you know
those bars
yeah so he opened this bar in charleston
it's amazing
uh it's called uh uptown social and he
he he started uh doing breakfast on the
weekends
bacon egg and cheese new york style yeah
nice kaiser roll
of it killing it people don't people
think he invented it oh yeah they have
no idea
invented it it only really exists it's
like on the you know the mid-atlantic up
yeah like philly dc up and to boston
that's so simple bacon egg and cheese at
a good bodega
[ __ ] orange juice can't beat it yeah
good night yeah
i'll go get one right now that's the
thing too you can get it any time of day
oh and whenever
it's awesome you might have to wait a
little bit extra for the bacon if they
don't have it like already
i don't even eat the bacon turkey bacon
there you go well since we're on food
and you mentioned it before what would
what's yours on food what's your go-to
at a diner
what's your go-to meal okay my favorite
dining after a show
i got 23rd and 9th chelsea square diner
i've spent many nights there i had at
least five thanksgivings there
hold on that's right hold on i was gonna
i swear to god
i was gonna ask him because it's a new
york thing i was gonna ask him if he
ever
had thanksgiving at a restaurant you
just told us that you scoop your bagel
out yeah yeah you're
you're on you're swimming on the other
side yeah i have my answer
and you didn't think to hide that
information from us
[Laughter]
thanksgivings chelsea square diner at a
diner
they probably throw down a nice turkey
here's the thing oh sorry oh
my god uh here's the thing chelsea
square diner
um we would go there uh
after clubs all the time and i don't
celebrate holidays like a five percenter
you don't believe in the
white man's holidays stolen land from
the natives
all that [ __ ] you don't believe in that
fair enough but i love
thanksgiving food
so so i can't [ __ ] with easter but i
love people
so thanksgiving eve in the hip-hop world
i think thanksgiving eve is bigger than
new year's eve yeah party-wise yeah yeah
that's for a lot of yeah party-wise
thanksgiving eve is better it's more fun
uh new year's eve is a bunch of amateurs
that don't know how to party
thanksgiving is the night and uh
thanksgiving with dj a club and then we
would go to chelsea square diner and get
and you can get this right now they have
it all the time oh yeah yeah they have
the thanksgiving you get anything in the
diner all the time that's what the trash
part comes in yeah yeah yeah yeah you
can get thanksgiving dinner
i'll do i'll do uh depending
on the time of day i'll burgers are a a
go-to for me
always do a good burger um and then i'll
do a
uh i'll do a grilled cheese on rye
which is mostly new york they don't have
rye everywhere
good jewish rock yeah northeast they do
yeah yeah yeah they had it you get a
tomato soup with that or just the
grilled chicken
i've done tomato soup with it okay
[Laughter]
grilled cheese on rye turkey bacon love
it
uh make a grill dude a diner makes a
great grilled cheese
see i you know what i'm i'm stuck on
chelsea square diner cause i know the
whole menu
i'll get a mushroom soup they got a good
mushroom soup
fried mushrooms uh fried mushroom
appetizer
yeah like the like little breaded balls
mushrooms know them well
uh the best ones in new york are neptune
diner
in astoria sure neptune diner right off
the
the rhinostoria boulevard yeah right by
the bridge um they have the best fried
mushrooms those because i used to live
in astoria
but um burger onion rings
because fries like i like fast food
fries sure so in a diner i'll do onion
rings
the gentleman moves but he's also
getting [ __ ] i was [ __ ] back
god damn it i don't know what's going on
i made my predictions kid's slippery
sorry i'm sorry i have all i i have all
i need
to render my verdict and it ain't good
for mr sippy sounds
[Laughter]
when's the last time he had quail egg
106. uh
quail never never had a quail egg no
right
i don't like slimy foods i don't like
slimy foods
i don't know if that's trashy or classy
i don't know like i don't i don't i
don't
like even if i do eggs i gotta be well
done
i can't do the the yolk and all that all
right he's trash
that's it that's a wrap really a [ __ ]
gentleman has a sunny-side egg
no so you can dip your toast in it it's
gross no
my vote doesn't count but i say this
guy's all classy he's doing cannonballs
yeah but it's all it's all on borrowed
time nothing
nothing makes sense he's buying a house
with a [ __ ]
air force one box hundred percent
garbagio yeah
i go on the road with the best i go on a
roll with dave chappelle
michael che michelle wolf like these are
my friends
yeah four uh four seasons rich carlton
uh all all day top of top top top
if i go on the road with myself i'm on
hotels tonight
every hampton inn yeah i'm fine zola's
is clean i need to clean
hampton you're doing well
holiday in express do you hit the
continental breakfast in the morning i
don't
i don't i'll go i i'll spend on food
okay
i'll spend all i'll give you that yeah i
don't know what's the what's the room
che used to get me sweets yeah cause
he's a gentleman
he would get me sweets and this is how
you take the buy out go ahead go down
[Laughter]
listen we gotta leave i'm gonna tell you
right now here's the thing
michael che the nicest guy in the world
greatest guy he gives you the best
first class treatment my thing is i'm on
the road with him
three four months right summertime
before when he doesn't do snl
my thing is his accountant at the end of
the year is going what the [ __ ] is all
these
two why do you have two suites yeah yeah
the suite costs more than what he pays
me
[Laughter]
so i don't want to be in that zone where
you look at that's march
yeah all of a sudden you're an expense
expense so i'm like just give me a
regular room it's still a four seasons
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen cypher sounds buddy
this was fantastic that's a fun one
anything you want the folks out there to
know you got coming up et cetera et
cetera the main thing i want you to know
is that when you do a podcast you
for supposed to plug in the beginning oh
listening at the end
[Laughter]
a lot that's trash
we get long haulers baby plug in the
beginning
look just follow me at cypher sounds
it's a weird name it's
c-i-p-h-a follow me um
juan app is dead podcast me and peter
rosenberg
uh it's back the fans wanted it we're
we're back
and uh everything on there now that the
world is back open you can find
everything on cybersounds.com or at
cypress sounds
fantastic awesome man thanks for having
me this was amazing
great kippy what do you got for him uh
just make sure you're review subscribe
on itunes
uh youtube you can subscribe there
patreon.com and then the live shows we
have coming up we're
announcing probably like four or six
more coming up yes sir but the first two
are um what the [ __ ] i'm drawing a blank
raleigh and that's riley good nights
nashville carolina nashville zany's
nashville's get those [ __ ]
babies come and see us yeah we love you
guys we'll see you next week cypher
thank you
thank you